hi my name is Vivian Zhang I'm a junior
working in the Elm lab doing microbiome
research and my current project revolves
around this treatment called the fecal
microbiota transplant this treatment
involves taking the stool from a healthy
donor and transplanting it into the
Dutch of a sick patient and this is a
really effective cure for a disease
called recurrence seed of infection
however it's not really that effective
in many other diseases that are
similarly related to the microbiome and
we want to we want to look into
you know what effects the efficacy of
fmt what factors you know play into
whether or not the bacteria and the
Stoner and the donor stool colonize the
patient gut and the so the two factors
that we looked into in my project one is
whether or not the stool prior to
transplantation was exposed to oxygen or
not the idea behind this is that your
gut is a very oxygen deficient
environment but the processing the usual
processing method currently used in
clinical trials and in medical centers
involves exposing the stool to a large
amount of oxygen and so perhaps this is
that's enough to alter the the
microbiome composition of the donor
stool sample enough that it impacts how
well how well the bacteria colonize the
patient and the second factor is to look
at whether or not perhaps the sheer
difference in the donor since since
everybody has a very different
microbiota composition perhaps just
enter donor variations have a large
effect on whether or not it's on how the
on how the donor stool interacts with
the patient so we did a clinical trial
with three donors and 11 patients we
took stool samples from the donor and
from the patient both before and at four
time points after the treatment was
given and long story short we looked at
the the composition of the stool samples
and so far doesn't seem like there's a
really large signal to indicate any
difference between patients that were
treated with oxygen exposed or oxygen
not exposed to oxygen stool and what
might be either covering any signal from
for any signal from that effect or which
might be more important than whether or
not the stole was exposed oxygen is the
inter donor variations preliminary
results indicate that the stole from one
of the donors was perhaps worse than the
other two donors in for the bacteria to
colonize in the patient gut and in the
future I'm going to do some more analyze
analysis of the data looking at more at
specific bacteria whether those perhaps
do differ between oxygen and oxygen
exposed and also looking more at you
know are the donors specific effects are
they because of the differences in the
composition are they perhaps artifacts
of how they were processed to get to the
just try to get at the bottom of the
mechanism behind FMT